a los ocho años por atropellar y causar
heridas graves a tres policías entran
dentro de la normalidad del derecho
comparado pero esta sentencia era
inédita por la consideración de la
bandera que llevaba al joven donde se
podía leer liberación con la revolución
de nuestros tiempos sus abogados
insistieron durante el proceso que era
ambigua y política pero el tribunal en
una sentencia de 62 páginas asentado que
en realidad era una incitación a la
secesión la sentencia en la práctica
finiquita cualquier posibilidad de que
regresen las protestas porque ahora
llevar una pancarta o gritar una
consigna puede ser castigado con varios
años de cárcel de hecho un zintan de
pekín pedía estos días que otras
consignas célebres durante aquellas
protestas como cinco demandas ni una
menos también puedan ser penalizadas
esta es la primera sentencia que se
dicta bajo la nueva ley de seguridad
nacional que divide a la sociedad
hongkonesa para unos ha devuelto la paz
y la tranquilidad después de meses de
protestas violentísimas que llevaron al
territorio al borde del colapso para
otros en cambio
realidad la peor de sus pesadillas que
hong kong se acabará convirtiendo en una
ciudad china más